Hallo Wolfgang. Hallo Stefan, wir sind in der Garderobe, gleich geht's raus auf die Bühne.
Aber zunächst wollen wir noch sagen, was wir im nächsten Salon lesen, also Anfang Januar.
Und zwar werden wir uns mit einer Soziologin beschäftigen, die ihr Leben,
ihre Wissenschaft den Gefühlen gewidmet hat.
Eva Illus, sie hat ein neues Buch geschrieben, das heißt Explosive Moderne.
Wir können gespannt sein, ich kenne sie nur aus diesem Gefühlszusammenhang,
aber sie ist Israelin, hat sich deswegen da auch immer schon eingemischt und
wir wissen ja, Gefühle und Politik, das ist gar nicht so weit auseinander.
Denn die Liebe und der Hass und so, das was die Politik foltert,
ist natürlich auch in der Gefühlswelt grundsätzlich anzutreffen.
In deren Sicht glaube ich auch, das wird ertragsreich. Ja, wir haben ja schon
häufiger über die emotionale Komponente in der Politik oder die politische Komponente
in der Emotion gesprochen.
Und ich glaube, da haben wir jetzt die richtige Autorin, die uns viele neue
Begriffe liefert, Analysen bringt. Und wir widmen uns jetzt auch großen Gefühlen.
Wir gehen jetzt raus, gleich gibt es den Live-Salon.
Und ich kann dir sagen, ich will an dein Mitleid, ich will dein Herz öffnen.
Denn ich habe mir die gesamte Gala angesehen von Ein Herz für Kinder,
ausgestrahlt im ZDF, veranstaltet von der Bild-Zeitung.
Und ich kann sagen, wenn man wissen will, wo wir in Deutschland ideologisch
2024 stehen, dort erfährt man es.
Ja, ich befürchte. Ich habe da die Clips-Sammlung gesehen. Es ist viel.
Jetzt werden die Protagonisten vorgestellt. Ich habe dann auch eine CDF-Sendung.
Gestern war bei Markus Lanz im Jahresrückblick Markus Söder zu Gast.
Und nachdem wir, wie ich finde, es ist unsere Leistung gewesen,
Deutschland erklärt haben, Lindner ist schlecht und dann hat es auch der Kanzler
verstanden, möchte ich, dass wir jetzt neuen Anlauf nehmen, diesmal haben wir
nicht zwei Jahre Zeit, sondern nur zwei Monate, um Markus Söder geil zu finden.
Wir feiern heute Markus Söder.
Überrascht dich das? Wie muss ich mich darauf vorbereiten, um das durchzustehen?
Also sehr kontraintuitiv vermutlich. Ja, du kannst ja nicht flüchten auf der Bühne.
Ja, also ich bin sehr gespannt auf die Herleitung, die du uns dann da machst,
da du ja jetzt nicht als Söder-Freund bekannt bist.
Ja, aber ich habe auch eine Argumentation. Du kannst mir dann sagen,
ob du sie überzeugend findest. Gut, gut.
Aber stell dich darauf ein, wir müssen Söder abfeiern.
Und dann geht es noch nach Notre Dame? Ja, genau.
Ich habe ja dafür geworben, dass wir Europa in ein Museum verwandeln.
Original getreu nach den alten Ideen und Ideologien.
Und was soll ich sagen? Ich saß mit offenem Mund fassungslos vorm Fernseher
und habe gesehen, sie haben es getan.
Zwar nur auf einem kleinen Fleckchen Land in Paris, aber sie haben es tatsächlich
genau so, wie ich mir das wünsche, getan.
Also hören wir uns das vor allem heute an.
Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf. Und wir weisen noch darauf hin,
dass man diesen Live-Sanon hören kann, Wenn man den Salon abonniert,
dann hat man auch Zugang zu all den anderen Folgen.
Das ist ganz einfach möglich, wenn man zum Beispiel bei Apple ist,
dann ist das nur einen Klick entfernt.
Man kann aber auch uns hören über Patreon, wenn man dort schon angemeldet ist.
Was wir präferieren ist Steady.
Man geht einfach auf die Seite neue20er.de, sieht dort einen goldenen Button, da steht Salon drauf.
Und dann kommt man gleich auf die Steady-Seite und kann eines der drei verschiedenen
Pakete buchen und hat dann für einen Monat beziehungsweise ein Jahr den Salon.
Die Jahresmitgliedschaft ist die günstigste, also mit drei Euro im Monat ist man da dabei.
Und weil ja Weihnachten ist, kann man es jetzt auch verschenken.
Genau, auf der Steady-Seite ist zu jedem Paketpreis unten auch ein Geschenke.
Ich glaube, da ist sogar ein Geschenksymbol.
Also man kann es nicht verfehlen.
Es gibt nachher auch Geschenke hier im Saal. Also falls ihr nicht heute hier
seid, sondern Geschenke sucht, könnt ihr den Sahnaufer schenken.
Wunderbar, dann sehen wir uns gleich draußen. Bis gleich.
Guten Abend.
Hallo.
Vielen Dank.